saná vemos este calendario dos equipos
que realmente han destacado en el fútbol
inglés pero con estos partidos que
restan quien tendría la ventaja para
lograr el título de la temporada yo creo
que indudablemente en este punto y a
pesar de que es muy difícil predecir las
curvas de rendimiento de los equipos a
pesar de que tenemos hoy en día mucha
información por todos los imponderables
que tiene el juego emocionales
colectivos y demás la ventaja la tiene
el equipo de pep guardiola porque esos
tres puntos hacen que solo sus errores
hagan que pierdan el título yo creo que
más allá de la presión que puede
significar para club es disfrutar la
final de la champions league ya que este
liverpool se ha caracterizado por tener
una nómina amplia y sobre todo que ha
sido muy bien gestionada entre titulares
y suplentes en este momento pero
guardiola se puede tener un equipo 100%
concentrado en la liga y ya como lo hizo
en el primer semestre de esta temporada
es capaz de dominarla ahora para mí es
un gran premio que dos entrenadores que
han podido llevar a cabo un proceso y
que tienen ideas tan definidas en juego
de juego sus equipos estamos hablando de
un entrenador como guardiola que llegó
en el 2015 a su equipo como club que
llegó en el 2015 y guardiola que llegó
en 2016 a dirigir en la premier league
han podido establecer digamos esta
superioridad a partir de un trabajo
constante
entonces va a ser una definición
interesante pero creo que está muy del
lado del equipo de guardiola teniendo en
cuenta que además como como bien lo
mencionaba lo obtiene este fin de semana
ya otra nueva final en la eficaz frente
a chelsea ahora mencionabas en lo que
era el trabajo del liverpool tanto en
champions como en efecto como en liga
pudo haber afectado estos tres frentes o
todas las competencias inglesas en el
liverpool para que quizás le falte ese
toque final para alcanzar el título yo
creo que es apenas natural y tiene que
ver no sólo con la concentración sino
más con el rendimiento de los otros
equipos yo creo que en la premier y en
disputas tan cercanas estos puntos como
los que perdió este fin de semana
digamos al sector tottenham empiezan a
contar la gestión del club ha sido
excelente tal como lo decía y creo que
al final a guardiola al contrario lo que
le todo fue no tener una nómina tan
amplia para disputar la champions league
en este caso guardiola ha tenido que
enfocarse evidentemente después del
fracaso después de intentarlo tantos
años en la champions league
pero lo que le digo yo creo que tiene
que ver más es con un torneo que conoce
muy bien guardiola que incluso desde que
llegó en 2016 empezó a dominar lo conoce
muy bien y sabe hacer valer también la
localía que eso es muy importante yo
creo que estos jugadores no les pesa
disputar este torneo o tener esa
cercanía detrás del liverpool como si
les pudo haber costado en el torneo
europeo ahora por otro lado mencionaste
bayern ese empate frente al tottenham en
un empate que logra el colombiano luís
díaz que aporte le puede dar luís díaz a
este liverpool en la recta final del
campeonato inglés los de luís díaz es
muy interesante para los que no lo
conocen es un jugador de 25 años nacido
en barrancas departamento de la guajira
de colombia y lo que llama la atención
fue su adaptación tan rápida al
liverpool él llegó en enero y se ha
convertido una ficha fundamental de este
equipo de club ahora yo creo que es uno
de sus jugadores
que trabaja como aquel que sabe que solo
tiene una oportunidad en la vida pero
que también está tocado con el brillo de
los elegidos él no sólo juega bien sino
que ha sabido destacar en momentos
determinantes para el equipo yo creo que
esto tiene que ver como con cuatro
factores uno que técnica física y
tácticamente es un jugador superior es
un jugador que encaja muy bien en el
modelo de fútbol que llamamos actual que
llamamos moderno por otro lado que ha
estado acompañado por un equipo de
trabajo que le ha permitido tomar muy
buenas decisiones en lo deportivo hizo
una muy buena transición al puerto que
le permitió madurar su fútbol y llegar
digamos de una manera clara
al liverpool y luego el entrenador no es
un entrenador que sabe potenciar esas
virtudes y que desde el primer día no
sólo lo pidió sino que lo acogió y eso
hace que el rendimiento de este jugador
sea potenciado su jugador que juega como
extremo por izquierda pero que va muy
bien por el centro que sabe derrotar
posiciones que baja muy bien entonces
creo que va a ser fundamental en lo que
le queda al liverpool en esta temporada
ahora quisiera trasladarme españa' un
poco porque realmadrid de hoy consiguió
una derrota frente al atlético pero
obtenido la liga es mérito del
realmadrid haber alcanzado la liga con
tantos puntos de diferencia o hay
problemas en los equipos que están
peleando junto al madrid en esa segunda
posición el tercero y cuarto es
imposible separar los resultados de
todos los contextos y evidentemente
tanto barcelona como atlético de madrid
por diferentes razones estamos viviendo
momentos de transición barcelona por
tras una crisis institucional que les ha
costado
digamos no sólo desde la parte
financiera sino también sostener este
proyecto deportivo que los caracterizó
durante muchos años y atlético de
madrid- evidentemente con un proceso que
ves que ha estado muy consolidado pero
que evidentemente con el cambio de
jugadores y también sosteniendo la
figura del entrenador como diego pablo
simeone se hace difícil siempre
mantenerse en lo más alto de su curva de
rendimiento y por supuesto de resultados
ahora yo sí le veo mucho mérito al juego
del real madrid esta temporada y está
basado en algo que ya hemos comentado
aquí que es la figura de carlo ancelotti
como un entrenador que supo encontrar
herramientas desde lo anímico y también
desde lo táctico pero de manera muy
simple para potenciar ese grupo de
jugadores tanto los que ya estaban como
los nuevos entonces le pongo unos
ejemplos muy claros la llegada de álava
que entra en un circuito de manera muy
clara en la defensa del equipo ese
tridente que yo llamaría del mediocampo
que ha sido fundamental con casemiro
modric y cross como eje del equipo que
son jugadores fundamentales y luego dos
futbolistas como karim benzema y
vinicius que no habían logrado alcanzar
su pico de rendimiento lo logran hacer
en con carlo ancelotti entonces la
consecución del título yo creo que está
ratificada además por un rendimiento en
champions que no puede verse solo como
tenemos un tema de mística que también
lo hemos mencionado aquí la manera como
real madrid sabe imponerse en esas
situaciones bastante complicadas sino
que creo que tiene que ver con un
trabajo muy serio hecho al interior del
club que supo reponerse a tiempos
difíciles de falta de resultados digamos
para un equipo como como éste que
siempre necesita ganar así que le daría
mucho mérito a este título conseguido
por el madrid por supuesto ratificado en
final que se disputará el 28 de mayo
muchísimas gracias por todo este
análisis en materia de fútbol el día de
hoy